So we have 50,000 images for
training 10.
images for test
now let me
show you some of the pictures. I mean, we just saw it in the
on the website, but
we want to make it part of our notebook.
So here let me add some sections to
this notebook.
This is
import
libraries
and data
Let's call this part 1.
and then this will be
part 2
review
the data
so we said that c410 has 10
classes.
Sorry.
And what we want to do is plot.
a grid of
a grid of 10 pictures
and then when a loop over 25 samples
And then plot those so we will say.
or
I in range.
The range function will create a sequence of numbers.
So here we want from 0 to 25.
And I will say PLT Dot subplots.
and
this is index.
We want we don't this is not a Cartesian
or any kind of coordinate system. So we're going to empty out
the
like remove any labels from the plot
So we'll pass your empty list.
save for the y-axis
We don't want any grid.
again, because this is not a
coordinate system
and then we want to impose the picture or superimpose the
picture.
Well from each class.
So we have train.
images
and then we want to say yeah, I want to put the
class level of each picture and on the x-axis like
stable.
class names
train
labels
So if I show you the train labels?
up here
It's going to be a list within a list.
So if you want to preview a particular class.
we will need to go inside the list first and then
get the scalar value.
So that's what we have to
sets of square brackets
So what we once we run this code, this is why we should see.
No, this is not what we should see.
What did I leave out?
It's a plot singular.
and then I am
I am sure.
There we go.
So again the picture we just saw and but it's a good idea
to have them here and our notebook.